[SPEAKER_00]: yes colleagues a very warm welcome to this the 2026 african economic conference co-host of the african development bank group the united nations development program and the oecd africa has enormous economic potential potential that can create millions of jobs generate higher incomes and expand opportunities for all we know
[SPEAKER_00]: The tools that are needed to unlock this potential.
[SPEAKER_00]: We know the tools that work.
[SPEAKER_00]: The challenges to implement them, to finance them, to ensure they work together rather than at cross purposes.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is what your discussions today will cover.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it is where the OECD is focusing our efforts in partnership with countries across Africa.
[SPEAKER_00]: Enhancing trade and investment opportunities.
[SPEAKER_00]: Designing stronger education and skills policies.
[SPEAKER_00]: and mobilizing higher levels of financing for development.
[SPEAKER_00]: First, on trade and investment.
[SPEAKER_00]: Africa needs simpler rules, faster border procedures, and greater data transparency in order to trade more and attract higher levels of quality investment.
[SPEAKER_00]: Even modest improvements in trade facilitation can significantly expand export markets and reduce trade costs.
[SPEAKER_00]: Reforms would also allow Africa to seize the potential of the massive expansion of digital trade around the world.
[SPEAKER_00]: Barriers to digital trade in Africa decreased to some extent between 2014 and 2025.
[SPEAKER_00]: For example, Uganda's 2019 reforms opened its telecom market by strengthening competition and introducing new licensing rules.
[SPEAKER_00]: And last year, South Africa introduced digital license applications for key professional services.
[SPEAKER_00]: The challenges
[SPEAKER_00]: to build and accelerate this reform momentum right across Africa.
[SPEAKER_00]: Second, skills and education.
[SPEAKER_00]: Between 2020 and 2040, the number of young Africans completing secondary or higher education will more than double from 103 to 240 million young people.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is a genuinely historic opportunity.
[SPEAKER_00]: but it will only translate into better jobs and productivity gains if education systems successfully equip the future workforce with the right skills.
[SPEAKER_00]: The OECD's Programme for International Student Assessment helps countries design impactful reforms to boost the quality of education systems around the world.
[SPEAKER_00]: Morocco was the first African country to join this programme in 2018.
[SPEAKER_00]: The 2025 edition of PISA will expand the coverage to Egypt, Kenya, Mauritius and Rwanda.
[SPEAKER_00]: We invite others to consider joining.
[SPEAKER_00]: Third, private finance for development.
[SPEAKER_00]: Bilateral official development assistance from OECD Development Assistance Committee members to African countries dropped by 24% in real terms, from $36.4 billion U.S. in 24 to $27.7 billion U.S. in 25, the sharpest annual decline since 2007.
[SPEAKER_00]: Larger and more efficient domestic capital markets in Africa could play a key role in cushioning the impact of shrinking development-wide budgets.
[SPEAKER_00]: Our OECD Africa Capital Markets Report last year showed that most debt and equity activity on the continent is concentrated in just a few countries.
[SPEAKER_00]: Egypt, Mauritius, Nigeria, and South Africa, among the four of them, across the four of them, accounted for 61% of the continent's total outstanding corporate debt in 2024.
[SPEAKER_00]: Encouraging cross-listing on multiple exchanges in the region and harmonizing debt market infrastructure could boost regional integration and promote capital market growth through economies of scale.
[SPEAKER_00]: The OECD is expanding our engagement with African countries right across the continent.
[SPEAKER_00]: OECD ministers welcomed the progress towards an enhanced partnership with Africa last month.
[SPEAKER_00]: We will soon begin consultations on this partnership
[SPEAKER_00]: with the African Union Commission, regional organizations and partner countries.
[SPEAKER_00]: And later this month, we're launching the African Virtual Investment Platform with 15 pilot countries to help African countries attract more and higher quality investment.
[SPEAKER_00]: We very much look forward to expanding this platform in the years to come to countries right across the continent.
[SPEAKER_00]: In closing, African countries are making remarkable progress on all fronts.
[SPEAKER_00]: Barriers to trade are lower, access to education is expanding, companies are attracting more capital, and the OECD has been proud to stand alongside Africa on this journey.
[SPEAKER_00]: We will remain your trusted partner as we push this transformation further.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you.